John Luke says he's in well good for you
he's in in rip rip rip oh come on all
right this time we gotta go fast we
could just gotta go frickin fast speed
come on speed through gotta go fast can
I X this I can't okay we got it we got
to sit through this guy's sit through it
okay let's do it oh that's me oh that's
me oh good news that's news that was my
name that was the Titan looks like you
have another character slot that you
could pick from hopefully we get through
this one and we just we're gonna do the
story mission first hell yeah oh yeah
here we go
[Music]
it's we've seen this office Acorah if
you tell me this is a practical joke
well it kills me to say it but I would
be really impressed impressing you Kade
is the easiest thing I'll do all day
let's get serious people
Zavala this is my serious face can't you
tell I Cora what have you got someone or
something has sabotaged the skyline
defense systems and comms have been
spotty for the last few hours every
sensor beyond the wall was gone dark hmm
maybe it's just the storm maybe it's
what are the set feeds tell us
[Music]
nothing that's good right no I mean
they're not there there are no
satellites and
[Music]
they're polluting
everyone
so class doesn't exist in the cage did
the Captain America that sounds like
this
yes
it's very
no the travelers light
[Music]
just so you know I know
I'm really scared right now why are you
scared okay oh is this what people were
saying no okay it's loading on the
bottom right I just don't know
hey just as a reminder it is a beta yeah
everyone freaking out about like
connectivity and stuff like that you
shouldn't it's a stress test it's
obviously gonna happen it's even in the
Bungie weekly you can see all the
different errors that they're that
they've shown now what I have to worry
about
[Music]
repeat Tao approach this is City Hawk
723 anyone home
no response on any channels even the
emergency frequencies what is going on
back there remember when I told you that
you fly too fast forget I said that
fly fast
oh dang that was needed this is new
footage oh really
[Music]
we didn't get that intro when we played
at the event cool
alright you're just joining us my name's
Rob this is Eric and we are starting
this close to beta test II - sounds like
a first mission homecoming yep
alright so my my I sent Nolan I am
setting over so you can trick which
between striker and Sentinel I'm gonna
obviously play Captain America
pulse rifle alright let's just check
this out huh yeah let's do it
should the jump spill a little different
not as floaties
I am striker my damage though okay laggy
there that was not it was not a skill I
don't think that was his skill now look
hey you want to turn on subtitles real
quick that'd be smart I think you're
right
check out the grenades stick it's still
the same as a defender time it would
have been an audio alright brightness
accessibility that's weird it's good
weird
we'll get to that later yep so as
someone who is an shooter dance emotes
perfect time to be dancing I know right
no I was just curious given the
situation are those your old guns tear
do they give you a random load out
random load up shacks my boy if you want
to give another shot you says subtitles
are under accessibility oh we just got
the sweet business Oh what addict it's
the same one from the thing oh yeah yeah
alright so what is it what type of the
it's a primary I think it's like a
Gatling gun there you go dope there you
go oh nice oh we're going through this
little pretty sloppy
so this was the same exotic as the one
in the at the vents while my super built
really slow
I wanted to Captain America so much oh
so it spins up like the longer you hold
down I think he has like pretty good
hipfire too so we should try that later
yeah how's the chat doing chats doing
good I believe how you guys doing the
chat I feel the same way hey Lia if it
ain't broke don't fix it they reiterated
on destiny once so much that like they
they figured out the formula you know
right that's what you're saying like why
why change it right yeah because I mean
like they're just tweaking it at this
point right mhm
you guys okay there and it's what
arguably what the first game was right
by the end of it yeah like it got really
really good by the end of it especially
taking King was such a huge right
addition
hello
nicer so oh this is this is all kind of
little these guys are not to crawl or
are they this is the Cabal football good
yeah
brawl is like the the big boss guy
essentially okay oh yeah I'm turn eight
we're out of primary
so this is the energy weapon I guess
it's got some solar damage just good
what would solar damage like fire damage
the command ship Rob okay so this is
more than what I played at the event
this look at the whole variation
potentially see what this punch is about
this epiha if you guys have any
questions in the chat do tell and I will
relay them to Eric here okay so that guy
has like a Solar shield right Rob so
theory your damage or your using this
and should take you field off what you
did oh yeah there's a third ability too
so there's that there's a little wall
bubble right talking about I guess I
can't shoot through it working it that's
all right so it gives us time to reload
or safely bring your swatches also for a
teammate TFC so that's kind of cool it
starts to crack a little bit he's like
nah dude I got a male am all blinded him
on the way in oh really yeah so now we
probably have a super avila I would
probably have the same effect in a
multiplayer to a PvP yep mm-hmm
is solo floaty so this is where like
people will probably explore a little
bit try to find those secrets I'm just
gonna proceed though as to not bore the
crazy the Xbox preload is going to be
for tomorrow oh it's a pretty load is
ready it is ready excuse me and then
that's for tomorrow
yeah Xbox one tomorrow 21st to the 23rd
for open beta heard that you need PS
Plus Xbox gold to like play everything
outside the store in the window that was
believed I was on the tweeters this is
where we started I think in that vent so
all that stuff before is
are there still fusion rifles I believe
so I think it's a thing confusion is
part of the the heavy which I have not
used it real talk I died here not
knowing that's about supposed to hide in
the balls bubble so you should guys know
a lot too
the ball back to my shield oh I'm
supercharged oh I can capture them out
okay we're gonna Captain America these
guys yeah you are after after they oh I
won't let them pass the gate Oh shadow
Hawk nine two fives in this game what's
up oh okay so that's that okay left
click throws it it does bounce confirm
oh oh we need to
it sounds pretty cool that's weird I
couldn't throw it again I was a spamming
the left click button which was how I oh
no I'm in died then Ebola so Monash
green wants to know or I don't know if
you could speak all right but uh
leveling up is difficult is it better in
the game hard to say because I've never
had to level up in this game
I started at this 200 or whatever and
that's kind of like just kind of how it
was based oh we got another guy Ken Ham
oh what's up guys how you doing those
are real people you think I don't know
oh they're dancing they're real ha ha
they real oh god there's where's your
shield oh yeah we supercharged again oh
he dead because he didn't stay inside
Danny don't listen to the valla oh where
they at
I got AI got a I got Captain America for
them so it looked like he said it was he
was letting their eye through it once
now why can't I throw it again why
can you block with it trying different
buttons up you died
oh there's on row huh I always seem like
that I don't know if that's just me
maybe I have to look at this super thing
later
see if there's a because you can pick
your how your super interacts so Josh on
the chat was surprised that this is not
a multiplayer only so there's a strike
mission yeah there's a strike mission
Tori mission and then as well as PDP
right correct yeah two different PvP
modes both are for before one is the new
kind of like counter striking mode where
like you set a bomb off or whatever your
appliance upon rather sorry and then the
other one oh that guy Oh
we gonna die because we all didn't
listen to the ball of your own hot tip
you didn't I know I didn't realize he
did it that many times like it didn't
happen this many times I think you know
what it is is because I did solo and I
think since we're teamed right now it's
prime or enemies which is cool is he is
he saying like yeah he's he's saying get
back I'm just talking on a cannon I hear
myself also we're supposed to go to the
next area I think yeah nice timing but
you know everyone just wants to kill
stuff alright here I'll lead the way
I am the Titan after all you got a
Pokemon - to answer on any questions to
the best of our ability to the best
let's go we gotta go - where's yours at
what's up Jason what's up welcome Oh
what's this guy it's just doing some
janitorial ooh you my friend
keep up he's probably not useful in any
other way that's pretty hard oh I Cora
she's pissed oh dang I'll dance with you
I Cora
will you dance with me look at that
oh no problem I just blow up this [ __ ]
by myself
no problem Shasha wants to know solid
improvement or more of the same uh hard
to say Josh I feel like a lot of the
things that they were touting like story
wise and whatnot that's the stuff I want
to see and although the worlds and how
big those worlds are oh so these guys
are cool these are like those division
guys you can like blow them up and shoot
their tanks right so I want a snow is
fun yeah I want to see what's up with
the bigger worlds and that's what uh I'm
looking forward to and also they were
talking them like the rates gonna be
pretty pretty sweet - so yeah Josh I
plan on playing getting another track
you know we had that protesting one we
had that back stream I play it a little
bit but and I fell off tried to get back
in but I feel like I was too late oh
dude where are my buddies at they're
like still back there probably like
killing like all these like Redmen
football here I am by myself
whoo suck it it was definitely man yeah
it was like a nice little like food
stand before us that it's all cooked
yeah I was funny looking at your footage
from the destiny event and four months
ago but uh yeah you were just waiting
for your team the whole time I had to
just dancing all right you know what
it's time hello boys
oh so it looks like in like Auto chains
right yeah
what do you throw it oh I need a ride
Amanda I was only able to throw once
what's good bodybugg Oh Matt a former
clan mate of mine it's a pretty good I
mean I played it already so it's just
more playing you subclass she says that
about everyone especially you Rob
I actually haven't really seen a lot of
this because it was during e3 when they
first showed it right know during this
event why wait when do they show this
yeah
working diligently oh the throw has a
cool-down says Blademaster or even thank
you it's weird though because I threw it
right away and like I don't feel like it
even comes back fast enough for a second
throw but we'll see right because how
long is that super right like it's
decent though maybe the more I use it
though the supers feel more effective
than Destiny's one Andruw Jones the
striker one definitely feels more
effective than the old striker smash
because you can do multiple smashes with
striker now instead of just like oh I
used it once I blew my load so that's
pretty cool yep also did the there's one
person that was just like oh you know
it's like more the same and blah blah
blah I mean like I said they really
refine this game it looks a lot better
feels good and I didn't want them to do
too much different you know like
personally I don't know if people had
these like grand expectations but yeah
to me like why would you break something
that's like so refined and so good the
gun feel and everything feels really
good the sound quality of the the
gunfire is still some of the best in an
FPS that I've ever played so yeah uh
Tony pin rut you don't necessarily at
least from what I can tell I don't think
you necessarily have to beat any of
destiny one stuff or the DLCs to kind of
get where you're at because it's kind of
like its own story here I mean you might
not have as deep of a relationship as
you might have had previously with
certain characters well I mean I'm sure
they'll still flesh that out in story so
you wanted to be missing out too much
it's just like for anyone that's played
destiny one and they know who Kate is we
know who's the ball is you know who I
Corps is and we've built some of that
relationship already
whereas if you're starting fresh you'll
just be getting to know them for the
first time so how how much of the first
game will caught will pool carryover of
your ear character I think it's just
your it's just the look up here new
watchman call it's your what are those
things called the emblems I think are
the one things that are carrying over
and then everything and the look and
feel of your character is but then
everything else is not you know weapons
or anything like that the barrier comes
out pretty quick which is pretty cool so
you can kind of span the barrier a
little bit warm up on me I should have
did that earlier Zabala remember when I
died and I didn't listen to you yeah
that was my bad totally my B get your
ass in line Saiyans slightly different
he left like a pulse whoa like that's
new like a little flame flame wall
thingy
I should have switched to the grenade
launcher are there any others we haven't
seen much of that or I mean whether we
have but like it starts by better than
having a shotgun right now are there any
new character customization options in
terms of like how you like what they
look like or we haven't seen the
character creator if that's what you
asked out of primary that's good and
they won't be showing it here obviously
right probably not where is the big boss
guy there is
wrong braun strowman sounds like a
wrestler
it is a wrestler he's a really big dude
yeah bunch goman
bye to my SMG which is actually doing
more damage than my primary but probably
wasn't shooting this vessel oh that's
what's in the wall little nuisance
oh that big dude aha you can't treat me
there but nor can I
right your class MZ is your shield is
purely for like yeah like defending and
also like it does blind them right on
their way and don't worry I eventually
going
pick up that sweet ammo all right this
is oh this is okay so there's definitely
a little bit more in this one then again
what I played previously that's cool in
what respect just like just like this
there's more to this mission than at
what I previously played so this must be
the whole first mission potentially
oh I shouldn't have done that
I'm on fire all right
oh that other dude
I guess you guys are just joining us Oh
playing the opening mission of this
closed beta for destiny - you guys got
any questions - minute chat the nice
capital Q in front of it and I will
relay them to Eric here who's you play
this I mean it's as you said just a
little different from what you've played
but you already played this kind of
opening yeah so he could be so I think
this is where it ends
okay or not yeah thanks I packed Rob
thought Gary would be behind there he
was not
so here's my conundrum it's like do I
waste my super here or is there more
that is the real question
chant wants to see that sub class treat
when we're done from tyre we got we can
do that okay there's a dude let's let's
let's do it cry so where is it okay the
shield thing the shield throws on the
right or the left oh I might die here oh
come on went throw it again oh come on
it was so close to coming up cool down
oh you got it
where's my gallery
oh yeah yes yes you got it oh it's only
one of three no hey that's a pretty good
question says ask Kevin where'd the
other two players go I have no idea
also what the hell is going on here what
there wasn't cinematic to that like
butta maybe Oh like this is a really bad
idea
oh yeah that looks that looks a little
dangerous said enough of that it wants
me to go down there though and for some
reason my jump is all like get on the
left side are you just time it right
others are walkway there you hate this
job
yeah get in there
okay
okay so man okay it's a little tricky
this jump is so oh no oh no Rob no okay
there no load over it nice so that's
like a feather jump yeah it's not as
like I don't know the jumps are a little
more floaty in this game than they were
in one what you like or don't like I
don't like I don't like floaty jumps
want to get grounded quick
they didn't they're they're tired of
people tighten skating what's that it's
like where you could just like keep like
like doing like like little bursts and
then you could just like keep going
forward
Amandla
trash so you did all that before no none
of that laughing that cool I haven't
seen this either
without a cabal
oh my light guardian look at me creature
hey fuzzy creatures Yeah right
we forgot the fear
allow me to reacquaint you know my ghost
No
you're kind of Allah given
there's more predict anger man you
couldn't totally crushed you he's gonna
regret not crushing me damn right you'll
be back right Oh
ooh that's how we start at destiny -
cool Daniel you're allowed to express
your opinion now if you're gonna be like
negative like overly negative and toxic
then you'll probably get timed out or
banned but all right let's check out the
true evil is what you guys want so
here's a magnetic grenade which is the
sticky grenade which is the same as the
defender we are using mm-hmm you got the
void wall grenade and you have the
suppression grenade again those are as
they were for defender The Sentinel
shield
this is Captain America essentially so
l1 r1 you can hold l2 to guard which I
wasn't doing l1 to throw the shield and
then that has a cool down and then r1 to
just do the normal attacks like you
would if you picked up a shield in
previous that's a lot it's a lot to do
with that thing right yeah and then now
this is the extra ability so we have
towering barricade which was the one
that you saw me an interesting thing is
it doesn't say that they kind of get
like blinded but I definitely saw that
they were disoriented when they try to
walk through it like visually they're
like yeah they're like what's going on
and then there's rallying barricade
press and hold circle to create a small
barrier that allows you to peek over it
while aiming down the sights which
instant really sorry look instantly
reloads are equipped weapon when you
take over that's pretty good we can try
that one out now clover there
here's high-lift this is probably why I
didn't like the jump lets you jump to
greater heights strafed lift jump while
airborne to activate lift and okay so
that's a jump and then it's like yeah
catapult - in addition strong initial
burst was so like a faster like
beginning and then there's all this
stuff that we don't have upgrade points
for so shield bash after sprinting for a
short time use this melee ability to
unleash a devastating shield bash that
disorients disorient enemies
for your super I think so sold out like
a poor short time possibly yes
superior arsenal grenade kills recharge
your grenade energy in the trenches
kills while surrounded by enemies reduce
the cooldown of your super and second
shield gain an additional shield throw
that's what I would be using yeah sure
so was there like a ricochet
there was a ricochet sure but this gives
you 2 throws instead of one and then I'm
guessing the cooldowns probably better
so maybe we can get that unlocked I
don't think we're gonna get that
unlocked not ready never how would you
get an upgrade you know anything about
the upgrade oh not yet so it looks like
the looks like this is slightly
different there's less stuff that you
can pick from the options
it's just increased hipfire but who
knows right they might be yeah this
isn't final this is beta obviously so
anything it can change but yeah crazy
wolf can't find the Xbox preload not
much we can do for you bud
check out the store store I guess and
look for destiny to beta that's what I
would do there's a grenade launcher so
we'll switch to that don't know how I
still have my ghost considering you know
he pieced out on us so I can do quick
play multiplayer with new the other
crucible match I can also check my
roster out and see if these guys that we
know outside yeah want to do some of the
strike I'm down down to see that see if
we can get some of our guys in here if
not I got some some of my old d2 boys
story eggs
Navid you have to pre-order the game to
play the beta um to get it early to get
it early open beta is this weekend still
in store it yeah 21 to 23 21 23 thank
you let's invite Jake and John Luke
psyche and let's do it we're gonna wait
for Jake
[Music]
Josh says good ol D - boys - boys so you
call you guys D - boys no my clients
casual is F we'll see if Jake takes this
invite if not we can try inviting
someone else we can even invite Destin
lagari from IG and we want to owe the
lakhs bro it's Alex News house news
blouse you got Justin hey wall out there
as well people be playing people be
playing I don't know what or we can
invite Mike Michael
mehar D a nice playin story no he's in
orbit damn it Jake take the invite uno
mas
send him another invite sure so who's
Anna roses Grove yeah I don't know man
so a lot of a lot of the look obviously
this is all just random loadouts you're
not able to customize anything at the
moment I mean like you can customize
like the little things like we did that
we were able to but other than that we
can't we can also show the striker later
but I think since this is the new your
class we probably want to show that I
think I think you missed a treat under
the sub class all right let's take a
look mr. tree
doesn't look like it I did these ones so
do you see anything else that I'm
missing no well I guess I didn't do this
part okay what's this my bad
turned the tide your overshield from
defense defensive strike lasts longer
rallying force melee kills restore
health for you and nearby allies hmm
defensive strike kill an enemy with this
melee ability to create an over shield
around you a nearby enemy oh and ward of
dawn when super energy is full press and
hold l1 plus r1 to create a shield to
protect you in your allies oh so we
still have bubble so that's where it
went right that's weird why do I have
both press l1 plus r1 that's I hear
myself press and hold l1 in RR will try
that too
we'll just check it out one of those
guys needs to mute themselves or I'll
mute them for Justin there you go nope
don't want to the max for fire team is
just three it's three at least four
strikes I believe raid 6 and then PvP is
gonna be four before now crazy wolf ass
is the Warlock any different crazy wolf
yes so you won't be able to whoa why did
John Luke leave he's back
so he's different in the sense that
there's no more self res you get it's
the dawn blade now oops and you get to
when you use your super you get a like a
flaming sword that you can use to shoot
out flaming projectiles as well as like
melee with I don't know why he left Jon
Moss says I'm totally bored I'm not
bored I'm having a grand old time you
have a grand old timer
yeah and I'm not gonna play because I
don't know destiny that well and I'd
rather watch it and have Erick play
because the second I am given a the
controls I think people would lose their
minds oh okay snapped ad saying you get
to use both bubble and shield is that
one or the other though or is it that
once I initiate
my super I can also put bubble on yeah
it's been confirmed gotcha thanks nap JD
we can take a look at no we can't as I
say we could take a look at the ship but
you can't you can't all yeah it would be
no here's the inverted spire this is the
new strike at the front they didn't have
that different route that we did yeah
let's go boys go to Titans in a hunter
like the time of day looks different
Justin he's behind you go for the middle
bits where he's weak his soft spot am i
right for saying this looks a little
different yeah there's a lighting looks
a little different for sure yeah they
even said anything about like replaying
cool like oh is that like a different
area or you think this would change upon
like different replays I don't think so
okay I mean like it'll change in like
night falls and things like that in
terms of like what kind of modifiers you
have to deal with but the map will
always be the same unless they change
things up the future whoa that's new
that yes like a laser like a tracking
laser beam
we need to kill that guy voice all right
Oh phalanx has like a shield thing now
oh that was a getting a launcher that's
what oh that's why I did some damage on
you see it doesn't do what I thought it
would do but that's fine it looks like
the hunter got the same exotic hand
cannon that they did before it's
actually pretty good
so you see this is where I died yeah I
remember demo because these things are
like let's see kind of deceiving uh some
more weight okay maybe it's not like
molten glass I thought it was like wear
it like they disappear and come back cuz
that's like a big like destiny thing
they'll just have it where they like you
know Justin died down Guardian down
let's wave to him oh god I want me to
fall again I think so now this is
pre-order only beta for now it'll be
open on the 21st which I believe is
Friday crazy wolf wants to know what's
your favorite class so far Titan right
look Titan is my main I haven't played
the hunter arks rider yet so it's hard
for me to say played the dawn blade a
little bit at the event that felt pretty
good too but Titans always been your my
one and only might have much true okay
so this is the thing where reloads
when you're behind it yeah oh it's gone
I know there it is yeah rallying bear
kid yes I reloaded it my magazine so if
they stood behind it too they would also
get a mone gain especially for a machine
gun like this right stresses dead
friends just didn't play that much
destiny the first time around so he's
fine not used to he's got any weapon
type - like can I think overheat I know
it just runs out of bullets I'm about to
run out of ammo though for that one so
I'm gonna switch to our pistol a kinetic
pistol so you're right the I mean sorry
that's not connect this is the energy so
all the energy weapons that you have or
have elemental damage whereas the
kinetic is just as advertised it's just
like normal no elemental damage well
it's kind of neat I mean it makes sense
from like a I guess like a tactical
stamp one right like you're using that
to take off shields yeah yeah you
definitely want to have like within the
team composition it's ideal to have
different kinds of elemental damage so
that you can get rid of different
shields do you know all the yes void art
and solar from what we can tell no idea
if they've added anything new this is
also no maybe this is not because just
maybe it's just been a while but if I
were to guess would aren't be like I
kind of got freezing type arc is
electricity electricity poison no it's
just Boyd is like purple whatever that
is okay
do you like there's something down there
but we got shot at by something throw my
voice mails
oh he's advancing on screen yeah panic
sounds really real good
we'll say the sound effects are pretty
great in this game
dan got a lot of
rally to me my friends I don't know why
I'm reloading this thing's supposed to
reload for me that's for your teammates
as well right yeah and the range on this
is kind of butts though it's alright
we'll just give him some of the yeah I
agree until the environments and destiny
avoid enjoy has always been have always
one seems really awesome if you were
playing the other day it's like you're
in act like poor dork like electricity
like moving back and forth like I just
want to make sure it's tired of missing
press whoa oh there's just like one
platforming part up ahead that's kind of
like what I died to just now earlier
it's kind of annoying
we'll see how how often those guys die
or if I die I might die bunch do let's
see so I kind of like the short
barricade and I kind of don't because
the big one just soaks so much damage
but this is where like if you're on chat
like you would just like talk to each
other and coordinate like I would tell
Justin to have the bigger shield you
know right looks beautiful
huh hello buddy
laughing - Justin Justin what happened I
don't know oh we're getting sniped at so
yeah if you guys are just joining us
playing the inverted spire strike
mission now for Low's Sentinel Titan
closed beta for destiny - you guys have
any questions to come in the chat relay
them to Eric here who has already played
this can you say if it's any different I
feel like you were mentioning like
enemies coming up different enemies are
different oh and they've done and
because I've never fought against some
of them like they had different move
sets that guy I fought before but the
Sion laying down like the flame wall and
also just the Minotaur shooting like
that laser beam like that wasn't in the
build I played there was no vex I don't
think in the build I played from what I
remember crazy wolf with another
question
thanks to your will the season pass be
available afternoon I believe so usually
is but I'm not sure cuz I I remember I
didn't buy the the season pass when I
first you just kind of bought him into
it I bought it I bought the pack after
the fact that it but uh some people
bought it beforehand as like the one big
bundle sure which you could do to you as
well
I have increased accuracy with hipfire I
am out of primary again you know what
classes these guys are it looks like
hunter it's why our cry during justin is
tightening not sure if he said tunnel or
not but i would assume so what's the
yorkshire again the art super it's so
it's kind of like Blade Dancer except he
has like a pole instead of a like a
dagger like it's like a staff yeah it's
a good like a staff this I don't know
why I called it a pole but yes it's at
work site is correct I wish it Captain
America some people or we could try the
bubble thing to you which love to see
how that works all right there's a big
mine coming up right there like I'm
worth using she's the local wildlife
go my shield oh come on wait where are
you by the way what planet you know I
did not look this isn't earth I would
venture that it might be Venus but
there's a couple of you uh there's gonna
be new planets obviously right and like
I can't remember which ones I sound like
was i over was i oh the moon and the
[Music]
first game
shoot the bellies
do you keep your destiny once save I
mean your character looks the same if
you want to use your same character sure
the PC beta I believe is in like late
ourselves yeah it's a month from an hour
yeah I don't know if it has exact dates
yet I mean green nests iguana cool name
do you think the mini-bosses type
enemies with the bigger hell there he
goes he's our Carter oh he can blink
around that's pretty so that's cool
watch him go to town house neat yeah oh
it looks like you might have been able
to throw it to Justin died somehow again
in fact that question do you think the
mini-boss type enemies with bigger
health pools will be random during
patrols possibly I can see that in the
case being sniped someone please fill
the sniper
take care of this mess leggo anything
this is destiny - closed beta playing on
ps4 that's we are that's we are
[Music]
or dude stop
I think that's like Oh
so we need to feel doctor
and the only way to reach it is down
past those giants pointy drill bits
sorry I already forgot lemon is open
beta hope it visit 21st 21 her yep thank
you and that's not gonna be for both yes
platforms at the same time yeah yeah
just no PC yet right do these work yet
because we're supposed to jump to these
wow you're really sliding in there
this is gonna get hairy oh I remember
this y'all ready all right let's do it
oh god I lost so much health jumping
down there there's a bunch of enemies in
this room oh look there's a little
cleaver suit he's got so much life
yes well it makes sense I guess they're
like a melee type you know oh my god om
oh please do Ambo well you know what
your shield me that it doesn't like give
you a mojo just reload it right at least
I don't think it does we'll find out
right now
give me mo stay back
probably Andre just played the first
mission he felt the framerate to be a
little icky granted this is closed beta
for the final product but you kind of a
brief event it's extremely close I was
fine
how did that not hit him
you know like this is like when one of
us was supposed to super all these
little beads oh there he goes he was so
the first game had like pickups as far
as like weapons and stuff right kind of
like super weapons like well I remember
the first game having like I don't know
like hammers and stuff that you could
pick up and use for our period of time
oh yeah is that kind of the same case
look is this strike mission have any I
mean imagine if I haven't seen them yet
yeah and the missions like I said the
darn blade you get a sword already and
like with Sentinel you're getting a
shield right as a weapon so or like as
party or super it could've been
transferred to their exactly so they
might have just made it so like it's
that instead of like you picking
something off
send me to this area
Oh nope this is not a good place to be
yeah the life the life bar is on the top
there top center what's that
icon right below it no ghosts we don't
have light we're trying to reclaim our
light
oh yeah
as you guys can see this shield auto
reloads are done every time we get
behind it so we have to crouch hey guys
not gonna go kill it over he's got flame
shield
[Music]
all right here's that platforming part I
was all right
see how Justin does so my trick was that
I stayed at the high ground the whole
time but that's not looking like the
greatest idea we're about to find out
Rob nope we good we good so this was the
kind of cool stuff I thought or at that
I thought was cool yeah could also be a
pain in the butt though Oh cuz it gets
real of course carry some distractions
oh man hopefully you like push some of
these guys a little yeah y'all good
so nerve wracking
yeah alright we're gonna go we just
gotta go we just got to go oh oh oh
Oh
get over it here is that a crate than I
do yeah exploding crates oh not like a
not like a goodies crazy you wouldn't
want to open that up not definitely not
down here antifreeze you can play this
weekend
John Luke 8 v the bullet was just
chillier we all right
oh we kneel now we don't sit we kneeling
huh I guess that makes more sense
I don't know guys we over here I
shouldn't be wasting am I like my own
hello this is what happened to me at the
oh yeah hey down here oh Jesus
Justin there he goes oh my god I can't
believe he live
I can't believe he lived it was hard to
tell from our angle but it looked pretty
close
that was pretty sketchy I would say this
is where I think the boss area is gonna
be it's pretty cool I liked it I thought
this is cool like look that's a [ __ ]
minute ah right there what's this
so this is the first part we're around
so we got dropped down here and around
your screen here do you know anything
about that
yeah it's Mike quiet Mike Keith oh yeah
we'll probably be covering the PC beta o
partying down
just entirety apologies that ammo boss
it goes spawn where I'm at though or
stuff is not spa
yeah he's gonna spawn stuff to his thing
yeah yeah and then he teleports around
to
I'll clean up here
I mentioned he does teleport around
from downtown miss them
this pistol has hand cannon is like no
range go
that's that jump you have oh whoa hello
I looks like you like gain momentum when
you use it
sis Oh a little bit snipe on John Luke
what's up terraria Oh God
Oh
I like how that crosshair flips up not
cross over that scope oh we're going
down all right I remember this mo oh so
this is gonna get a little bit more
hairy obviously running out of space
running out territory mm-hmm mo
i sniffly oh yeah he does this thing
where yep he lights the ground on fire
oh cool so you kind of have to like play
a little lava
yeah little lava
hopefully he got just enough he did good
job don't leave
chris says anthem or this
I think anthem is so far away play this
verse and then deal with the Popo later
like you you'll probably still have time
after all that deal see for this is
outright like
oh I love it
and that's tough and the lava comes
you're like super exposed Huff is I
don't have any ammo these guys drop it
remind me like the colors white is
primary and secondary is that energy
right then purple is heavy so we just
got all of it so a game at least knows
like hey you're a Tamil huh did you go
to phase three so phase three we fall
through even more stuff and there's even
less watch I feet oh look at all the by
part right so that's the bubble so you
can still use both it's not giving you
giving you health it's giving us shield
[ __ ] when you're in there we and there
yeah oh so like when you're out it's not
like blessing of life
what's blessing of life is that I used
to give you shield on top of your health
and as the old defender so confirmed you
do get both
well there he goes Ark Strider and go
Chumley he's got a downward trend I
guess like a downward snatching always
blue now
he's getting he's getting living where
my boys at Capeside uh put down the
shield here Eric you were playing the
class Titan Sentinel Titan sent no time
the new the new subclass in the subclass
super has like a Captain America yep
consumed in a while because I used it
for the bubble said got it
Justin I need you to put that in your
bubble together our subclasses have they
confirmed how many it should be like
three each
so this is the cool thing I just
reloaded to play chillin off my
barricade there so for the Cabal they
obviously added a new enemy types
greener sorry green nest iguana is
curious oh that's a freaking blow-up
type ok have you seen any more or new
any types for like the hive
there's no hive yet that's for sure oh I
just got punted wow that does it
generate we might wipe here gonna save
him nope I can't yet
revives our other times there's pie
respawns if we wait long enough yeah I
just got punted up yeah so Justin
probably got a free vibe
all right you only have a certain amount
yeah
I'll get them here
down she goes oh it's a dance-off
so you guys do Oh what we got what we
got do I get loot ooh we got a copper
hallow a weapon we got a fusion right
that's not a fusion rifle that's not I
know it was a sniper rifle you're right
you've not seen that before no oh this
is different was this consumed okay not
different
oh they got shaders for guns now okay I
guess that's theory oh that's a lot of
shaders for that gun now we should
probably look at this end screen huh
yeah that's right 126 mm-hmm precision
kills 44 hello hello precise that was
only a third of my kills it feels kind
of bad so now we could try what respawn
announce four player co-op for titanfall
- oh really that's something else yeah
that's something else for another day
damn alright so we could striker Titan
if people want to see it we could PvP if
people want to see it what do you guys
want to see yeah well you guys want to
see I mean the logical choice teams I
don't know
pvp pvp I guess put that put that uh
Captain America to work you said it I
think it's actually a weird subclass to
use in bumpy but we'll see what is this
one this is quick play that's
competitive we'll go to quick play
Oh Justin's like nah no PvP tied marks
are now in the middle of the waste yeah
well it depends on which one you get
right sure other one I had was quiet oh
well no maybe it it's just in the middle
that kind of looks weird
hopefully that's not loincloth I've
never been a fan it's all hunters always
have it the best they get like okay they
get the Cape yeah or that yeah I'm all
about that hoodie can they get the Cape
oh there's the exact hand cannon they
all curious son shot oh look at that
solar flare damage on that's pretty neat
he damage mm-hmm
the side effect of the stunned shocked
son blast so this is like Firefly
essentially so weird that the exotics
don't have more like I'm sorry I was out
your chest oh we got copperud he has one
to you let's see here a lot of PvP looks
like Ark Strider PvP I can't rush art
Strider PvP that's what John Luke is
though right because that is not who you
well what was that not going that thingy
there's a new map playing control oh we
got one of the one of each I can try
making an arc Strider if y'all want to
see that defend the gulch oh we already
have see that's interesting so CNA
already captured it looks like whereas
he is where the action is
you could turn this time enemy captured
zone be smarty that video is kind of
funny it's not like he was whispering to
your ear hey I tried it kill dude he put
the big old shield on that spot that's
pretty good actually better than the
reload probably right so I should
probably switch to that as well oh hello
oh that was a mistake
are you crazy you crazy
damn oh my god that shields not gonna be
much switch switch it to the big one
don't really need the free reload I
guess good job psyche these guys are
playing it like it's TDM
Oh Oh what what oh that oh my god I
guess sticky doesn't one kill anymore
dad Oh power weapons is a new thing too
so some of someone grabbed the power
ammo oh oh so now tells you who has it
also the top shows you who has super and
stuff like that even enemies huh so you
it's just the super ammo right yeah I'm
sorry the power amp our ammo and then
you can lose your [ __ ] which is why you
have a grenade launcher yeah I think I
pick shotgun kind of bummed the shotgun
thank Jax thanks best vo
oh I thought I heard a but damn how are
we losing we have like two points let's
not be like scoring when we get the
point
exotic SMG teammate shield
hey sup bro sup oh [ __ ] was on behind me
- OH
shot me buddy oh nice Oh a grenade
launcher him I get B that guy died
hey like this guns like in the pulse
giggles pulse is one of my favorite
weapon types
I normally I'm not a huge hand cannon
fan because I'm not super accurate so
pulse is kind of my my fire bolt grenade
of course of course he fired both
grenades only scumbags use that oh god
sure though its overall
let's get away that that roll move was
for the hunter right yeah I wish I had
that right now gunslinger yeah I like
much I like the look of that just like
round corners run
well he chase yes
oh there's power in the left I was
really just trying to pull them away so
that my team could potentially get the
point but they didn't that's what I was
thinking oh we got shield hello oh yeah
two of them well it's in kill though it
didn't kill that's a bummer
Oh what was the hell yeah would you kill
them
Oh Golden Gun you also have we missed
he's doing the same
oh no there's other people here they all
suck that's what I'm gonna stick to that
Captain America's super does it have
been kill in one hit though yeah I was
shocked by that man it almost makes
sense though dude like that it doesn't
well yeah like if that thing is auto
change dude but it's a super it's a
super it should just kill in one hit I
mean that would have been a triple then
I would have been a double because it
bounced only on one guy yeah
as one I love it
to tighten tone hey secure you control
you guys are making a mess today come
back here what
so that bubbles does Dan Oh apparently
we should be using it more often
don't see captured all zones held you
have total control by vengeance a bad
spot to be in yeah I only have three
people now that I'm great
exactly we lost damn how do we lose plus
that's poop man that's poop yeah bad
start it's poop
I went I don't know it doesn't wow it
doesn't show Oh 2.5 KD but I finally it
wasn't good enough how weird I feel like
games are like dropping deaths you know
what I mean yeah they don't want you
know it's it's that kind of overwatch
feel we're like you don't feel bad about
how you played yes I do like seeing at
least KD though I thought really there's
like we can try Stryker if they want to
see that sure strike a few guys just
joining us this is the closed beta for
destiny - my name's Rob this is Erik
what's uh having a good time we are
checking some PvP right now uh what do
you think should we it's only 11:30 holy
God
yeah we'll probably play one more the
mattress oh yeah and then well we did
have 15 minutes of just like well
alright I guess that's one thing you
can't do anything yeah 15 minutes of I
don't feel like this auto-rifle is that
good in PvP so I'm not gonna use it we
did get a sidearm so we could try using
that you all want to see that the urchin
or yes no you feel like you know it's
not certainly it's a mold right but like
it feels good yeah it's like a like
upgraded of great version of destiny um
I like again it's so hard to say with
this beta like how much different is it
because we haven't been able to see a
lot of the big changes that they have
coming up which is like I said all those
new planets how big are those planets it
sounds like there's more NPCs on those
planets there's more stuff you'll be
doing on those planets also like another
quality of life thing is like you don't
have to go to orbit anymore you can just
go straight to the next area that you
want to get to so those are like all
like big changes alright we got the we
got the shoulders so then what's orbit
really for just like establishing a
fireteam and stuff more like more so bad
I guess
yeah that's what I'm the most excited to
see is like how that are not good how
these NPCs are gonna play out because I
do feel like a lot of the open world was
I don't know a little little boring a
little not useless but like repetitive
right like you're going down like the
exact same path a lot of people were
like clamoring and talking about story
and like you know right yeah like you're
gonna hope like NPCs have little bit of
story themselves
John Luke yeah there you go are someone
got him I don't let it slip in this
beginning there it is see like it's
giving you credit for kills that even if
I didn't get the last hit which is like
weird just like amount of damage oh oh
denied sorry got it sorry dude like is
that right is that that's what you're
saying like you know it's not necessary
to last hit it's like yeah as long as
you're doing damage you're getting
credit it looks like I don't like that
there's another guy am i right yeah
they're all I I guess we've swapped
spawns good looks like John Lewis got
grenade launcher ammo which is good
it's like Leonard yeah looks like titan
default gets to this is just a little
pistol the sidearm for that an act like
elemental right yeah that one's
elemental incendiary grenade I don't
know what the hell that was
oh I'm getting charged by something oh
is that one of those um could have been
a buff from the yeah had a war that
remember that want Kirk ability where it
was like for every kill you liking
health or something like that yeah lays
though Oh with melee yeah it might have
been from my little shield that I made
so it's possible
buddy that looks good take this succeed
oh yeah they are blond oh that's a it's
a good line give constructive criticism
calling names ain't very constructive oh
that guy just got two points yeah it
shows you a timer but now they all know
that I have a shotgun man that's kind of
a bummer why I don't know like no I like
I like the element of surprise with a
shock that you do favorite gun in
titanfall right I am definitely a
shotgun fanatic I just like making blind
corners just having that like reaction
oh I got it off before I could shoot
them poor play right now poor play you
need to play better
get to be so they come from guys so be
secure
alright that's so annoying oh man the
flank is real boys feel like my team
keeps wanting to take be like AMC points
they don't want to fight for our team
spawn points consistent like on each
side of the map usually somewhat it
depends on like if you have a point or
not okay like if you have a point then
your children earliness wander your
teammates broken up this capture yeah
probably
no they have all the zones thank Shaq's
what do you think about like less people
on each team because it used to be six
be six now it's four before no matter
what I think it is that consistent
across modes it is gonna be I believe
it's gonna be the new like kind of
standard oh that guy's strike you're
fighting right now I don't have much to
say but I do like Golden Gun Wow both
those cats we're getting rekt now yeah I
don't even get that a super I guess I
wasn't doing well enough it depends on
the game ultimately
but it's all about map size - right
how do you feel about it um I don't mind
it because I was playing a lot of trials
of Osiris which is there like 3v3 mode
so to me it's like not that bad
I think that it's harder to hide
teammates that might not be a strong
though
whereas in 6p6 you kind of like by
having more people could kind of mask it
a little bit but obviously they they
chose to do this for a reason so I'm
gonna play one more because I didn't
like how I did that
don't match absolutely go for it and
then we'll kind of wrap it up so if you
guys have any like final questions or
concerns or opinions shoot them over to
rob and he'll do put them in the chat
I'm gonna try to go grenade-launcher see
how that goes feeling so let's see so
Xbox what would be same time tomorrow
10:00 a.m. at least you have the lists
try that other no that's fine
I think the top day the other one to
help women on the far right I think that
one has time oh yeah that's 10 a.m. at
10 a.m. and then so 23 that's gonna be
Sunday right Sunday 10 a.m. Pacific is
going to be the social matchmaking test
available for one hour yep the farm will
be available and you'll be able to login
I'm curious actually that'll be
interesting to see how many people are
actually at the farm because no I think
in the past it's like 18 was the most
you could have in one tower so yeah see
play a little soccer yeah a little
Supergirl football at chest here a new
chest what does it look like oh yeah
digging it mmm
restorative Titan armor improved
recovery who's got more mobility but
this one's got more resilience oh damn I
want resilience but this one's got the
feathers so you know less resilience
yeah this is also difference too so it's
not intelligence discipline
and strength anymore its resilience and
mobility and recovery now we're going
with feathers so strength is resilience
I don't think they're that I don't think
they're not exactly one for one know
what it kind of sounds the same in a way
you know mobility agility any other
cosmetic items for guns slash armor
maybe of slots there were shaders for
weapons so we can show that we can go
through some of the menu stuff before we
took our dad feeling about this
how oh he's coming Wow you would think
that my punch would have killed him I
guess we traded Justin hey well with a
pretty good question if you ask me well
any of this carry over to the full game
I know there you have it No you'll be
replaying that first mission and strike
many of times yourself you're gonna
you're gonna play xbox one probably
right yeah you're gonna take a look darn
it yeah probably just to kind of see the
difference right dude why don't we get
up still early you're good you got this
oh yeah they don't even see you now they
see right lower two guys so weak please
finish them is it that same pulse rifle
I was warlock right it wasn't yeah we're
probably gonna grab that clip yeah what
do you think of a story so far
as Chris I think it's I want to see
where they go with the no light thing
like could that be
could the end of the like main campaign
if you will like could you get that
light back like yeah I think that's the
old kind of you know like to get back
there and and get get your life was
taken from yeah you know yeah or to live
to learn to live without it - yeah what
you get it back and don't even want it
you're like nah
Oh God Oh all right warlock melee range
is still really far boys and girls
warlock range and gloomy but I like it
melee range we're locked melee range
stole that kill mo gaming asked a pretty
good question because I don't think I
can answer it
uh what does light do again that's it's
like a how would you say it's like an
additional like leveling system right
like it has to do with armor pieces
right like it did in the the actual what
is it Grandview has what we have light
or a certain amount of light gives you
the power to fight the darkness man yeah
dog if you don't have light how can you
fight the darkness seriously is it like
how you like level up at a certain point
it was in the in the last game but
hopefully so you don't even really know
what they're gonna do it's a light then
huh are you getting up yeah I don't know
what's gonna happen in this one cuz you
took your light away from me so we'll
have to see wait come back ooh melee
range is kind of farther than normal I
think you hit that guy's a demonic
Adam's apple joked about his head how
didn't we not get that kill overall
that's a bunch of crap ya feel you did
well the spread isn't too bad since we
come back action yep there it is uh-huh
Oh rift breaker oh it was like now you
don't get to use this for some reason I
thought I had shotgun or they all right
we switched it can any launcher
I'm pretty good at shooting people in
the back
Oh kill clip it's part of the perk of
the gun I guess
and has a quick question if I didn't
play the first game but I've heard it's
not famous for its story is it gonna be
the same thing well what was that quote
that we had on our game spot our cold
like the the dev was like I hope there's
so much story that they're like there's
too much story in this one I don't know
what that the hell that means
too much story like they're loading this
one up with stories what that means yeah
well I got a double there but what does
that really even mean
so we'll have to see I mean I we're
gonna lose everything I myself like was
like just a recap of what whatever story
was in the first game just to kind of
like set people up I'd like to know
before I dive in because I will give
this in a shot myself goob asked what
class would I play armors looking hot
though well class should I play well
class yeah you're right more like a
hunter guy I think no actually that's
not true you like shotguns so probably
Titan I do like sure you need something
someone that can take some of that
damage before like but anyway anyone can
wield a shotgun right yeah yeah but
certain classes have more like all they
used to at least have like more
application or application like you
could go full resilience right like I'm
gonna die faster unless I put this arm
it looks so much cooler so I guess this
is a PvP gear phoenix strife and then
the noble stuff is like what you start
off with for PvE looks like like these
still don't do anything so yeah there's
shaders for I guess like everything now
it looks like oh let's see you can
individually shader I guess is what it
looks like you can mod gonna get an
armor mod whoa what is I don't know
maybe just like some cool spikes or as
you said though I could increase my my
health
instead of
my recovery is that my mobility three
good my resilience Chris Hatter says are
we getting grimoire cards again probably
not like I think that was that was a
substitution right or like ah as long as
their story present in the game like
because those were outside right
grimoire cards you would get them and
then you would have to go online the
read them or something yeah you have to
go online looks like there's only one
pvp map I guess okay sorry I guess one
up this in here so there's the last one
for sure I'm down alright I feel like
you're itching you need you have got to
have a good game you need you want
Redemption knife Elia I also really want
to Tiger need someone oh [ __ ]
now get on with that what's this nade
you have here lightning grenade grenade
oh it hit someone no you're done
I think the trade I'll take your trade
you kill me with the red mama
Mambo Mambo number 5 sure we see you
yeah that's why I've heard three more
carts over the store
so he isn't like crucible like the
training grounds more or less isn't that
what it's like ice it's like a if there
was a narrative to it it's like a
simulation right we're simulating here
cuz they're like kind of factions -
right yeah they're they're burning in
their that all that guy almost died - my
shield walk through it I love it
power overwhelming no idea what that
means here's here's your win already
twenty six two five hot yeah the prize
price will most likely be $60 I don't
see why it wouldn't oh yeah for sure for
sure however the season pass do you know
anything with that with you would you
tack on another another forty on yeah so
I'm making an even hundred dollars
brandy that'll last you how long a year
yeah at least two DLCs worth I went to
could test it that was dumb I should
just try to fight on kill him you got a
nice lead here though
yeah I hope so oh we are in the lead I
guess I'll try to break them force them
back to a I see you I see you I see you
too Wow no I wanted to shoulder charge
I'm so bad I just want to charge this
game's gonna go quick you think so but
slash arm Oh nicely done here's what you
don't let up new this what was that
that's print so when I sprint for a
while that's when I get that shoulder
charge that's got it up trying to do to
those guys with me Brendan wants to know
for playing the warlock and hunter a bit
later unfortunately probably not as far
as this live stream but we will be we'll
have put a joker footage all throughout
the week
Oh daddy back dr. holder doesn't kill
that's what dick ridiculous shoulders
charge does he kill wanna hit anymore
what's the point what is even the point
then like a lot I mean other I don't
know dude what is even the point if the
shoulders charge isn't unless I get just
got unlucky see if I could build up the
shoulder charge but maybe that has a
cool-down - now if you're a curious why
circle the a shoulder charge does a
cool-down 100 percent goop says yes no
more free kill what do you mean no more
free kills I don't know what does that
even mean I don't know he says no charge
because you're a cheap player that's
what he's saying sheep that's what I
realized he's cheap
knowing sayonara secure what are you
been Gingka buzz your girlfriend whoa
that's cool shut down I'll say that
so smash isn't one-hit-kill anymore
either which is interesting so I had to
follow it up with another attack just
shoulder charge oh boy mom you need like
some running speed right not in super so
in super you can just keep doing it
right now we're about the series of
different moves yeah do you throw guys
back when you do that I know you just
like push through them I got a Morgan
bleep whatever that is all right
fifth graders and staff kind of I don't
know those an okay one too much trying
to shoulder smash somebody it's not a
mistake
I will point a nine trash trash
efficiency you're so hard on yourself
it's real trash efficiency well you'll
get back to it yeah we'll get back to
this right after are out of here that's
that's been it we had a pretty great
stream in my opinion that was cool to
look at I will be playing this myself
definitely yeah I mean so you guys know
today's ps4 beta if you pre-ordered
tomorrow will be Xbox one closed beta if
you pre-ordered the 21st will be when
its open beta as I mentioned before I
believe if you don't have PlayStation
Plus and like Xbox gold you won't be
able to do multiplayer I think is what
it sounded like
but yeah understand you still get
single-player so you can try that out
check that out see if you guys like it
thank you guys so much for watching
thank you rob for helping host this
morning thank you yes
props to you that was a good run glad we
got into it at some point there's a
little bit of that delay but that was
kind of expected in my opinion is a beta
it is a beta but yeah thank you guys so
much for watching do give us a like and
subscribe if you want to see more
destiny content and yeah Friday get to
try this out for yourself
so until then slobby tomorrow at 11 by
bad control only one part of victory
Guardians after the zones
destroy